Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to Crashworld. Now Crashworld is a game where you're a pizza delivery man
Sorry yes right on to the hospital
It's a game where you're a pizza delivery guy, and you're trying to make every possible delivery possible fire exting
What does that even mean alright anyway? So there's it? You'd love a pi- okay? You know what I'm just gonna go for it
I've never played in today. Hi. How's it going? I'm gonna. Call you. Oh Uncle Bing
Oh, is that Bingipliers dad? Can I change my name? Oh god change name, okay? Ah?
You're so into me. Okay, although...ahh
Okay, all this crashing aside and explode. There's a tire oh
There's screaming though. Oh god. Can you stop?
Just leave him alone
He's already dead the thing that tree have sent alright. Good thing that tree of censorship
It's right there in the way, so nobody knows. Okay. I'm gonna call myself
Blasty
Where did I go blasts team?
Plodey, that's me baby. Hi player goddamnit. My name is Blasty McSplodey
Just call me blasty come on please I'm begging you
Call me blast me and uncle Bing open up a pizza place get rid of hotdog vendors
But your turf in this endless delivery run
Why is it endless?
I'm gonna look at this button cuz weird and questionable, and I like weird...it does nothing. Oh god. What did it do?
I'm sorry if I blew anybody up. I'm gonna change my ride oh fastest pizza car in history pepperoni powered
I don't believe that I think you're lying suspicious limo this car looks rather suspicious
Is it cuz there's people banging in it or there's dead bodies in it?
Or there's dead bodies in the pizza or uncle ping actually isn't my uncle Stang pizza. Delivery. Just got seriously
I thought you just said excuse my beauty I thought you just said that that was the fastest pizza delivery truck all right whatever hat
That no, no hat you going naked maybe...Oh
Not a hat for me I have for the car well of course. I should have no-.. that's a human
*Laughing*
Jesus friend hat don't go alo- bring a friend
*again laughing*
Funniest thing I've seen all day. Oh well All Right see ya well, then okay, all right, I guess...bye friend
oh what the hell I feel like a flamingo today
Beer keg never leave home without your beer keg yeah, I mean that's my usual policy cuz
At any moment I could take a drink while I'm driving and die
Both from the alcohol and from the driving and drunk ladder act going up
gravestone act the land of the dead
extra exhaust hat
So my car can vape I understand I see what you're doing here
Alright gas at its gas bottles on your head press space to activate
I don't know if I wanna do that
I don't know if I wanna reenact that episode of mythbusters' friend hat
friend hat boink aohh
is he dead? friend? how many friends can I spawner Oh God?
Never ending friends it's an avalanche of chairs. This is the greatest thing I've ever seen in my life by the way
I don't know if you guys knew, but this is the greatest thing I've ever seen in my life alright well
I gotta go I gotta I gotta go with the friend hat
But I just can't not go with the friend hat I have to right. excuse me My god actually this game
Isn't just about putting my friend on my car. I got to deliver some pizza
We're open for business, and we made all these pizzas, but these hot dog vendors are killing us
So let's kill them
trash them and watch out for the cops
I'm going up going God, okay?
See you uncle Bing no mercy sure thing okay alright, then I'm not pressing a button
I guess alright. Let's take it nice and easy I got my what up homes. How it do
Let's take him nice and easy I got a friend on my car
Shoot me. I haven't done anything
sir I
I did nothing I did nothing I had nothing to do with that
I had nothing my money long hey darling. I am doing nothing
I just want to say I got a friend on my hat and that's it. I'm not resisting. I am complying sir
Ma'am all right here
We go hold on friend get these nutritious apples cuz that's what's important there wreck the hot dog guy
Why I'd I tried you know I actually tried, but my instinct was just like I shouldn't mer-
What is happening to that dog? Are you shooting me?
Okay, now. It's just so
That was just self-defense at that point. Oh, I am
so sorry ah
Sorry, oh. Yeah. Yeah. Oh, yeah, yeah, I am so sorry okay
That's a dent. I think I went for a wrench which helped apparently
All right
Man this game this game is fun, but it runs like a potato Wow
Wreck you hotdog man
Hello sir don't mind me why is everyone so angry. I'm just trying to deliver pizza well actually
I'm not but you know happy god. This this game has like two frames a second. What is going on
Boink okay all right then yeah, I got ya yeah
Yeah, let me change some settings the graphical fidelity is just too extreme hello hotdog man. excuse meh
Sorry, okay, all right. I'm gonna actually try to play this game. Well now I mean by well
I mean I'm I'm gonna go around town and murder hot dog vendors for some reason
Sorry excuse me what up homes all right. Good pardon me all right yiii where my friend go my friend
Oh not worth it
I'm sorry. You'll be back your back is halfway across the city
That's good. Joke alright
God is running late potato again
I hope that when I'm meeting my imminent demise I have enough wherewithal to say
Shout at the top of my lungs fool. I'm gonna. I'm dead aren't I
Well then scores yeah, let's see how I did woo, oh, that's why it was saving replays Oh
Woo
You see me you should see me you practically crashed through my window to see be so funny
Hey, I gotta go get my friend. I gotta go get my friend before I do any of this profile
No, not that not that okay
Play... get my friend there is
Darius that's mobile while please hotdogs fondos are calling me
Truce them and woot shoot for the coops poop in the boots of couch cushions and smoosh
I'm going I'm a smash Uncle Bing. Don't worry about me. I'll worry about me
Oh right, the hot guard. Oh good. Good. Good. Oh come get some iron. Got some. I didn't like it. Oh
Repair don't hit me don't hit me I'm a ticking time bomb oh
Well, I'm probably gonna die how can I I'm gonna? I'm gonna make this conflagration the most
Epically damaging possible ah good yes there comes my no frames flap
Thank you. Sorry. I really I'm not sorry at all actually in fact of the matter is that?
Yeah, I better get these apples fix up my car
Excuse me sir a nice striped shirt. I loved you in undertale. Hey gray
Well doesn't help when I get the repair thing and then immediately hit something else sorry nice mohawk
I got no frames
I got no frames. Oh God
Wrench well pit wolf that wrench was completely negated
Yeah, I'm not sorry at all
Where's my stripper
It's the fire truck guy like the fire truck got there too late. He's a friend. What ain't friend?
You know I forget I was saying anything friend who's just look shut up mark God
Adam you proud of me Uncle Bing
I'm murdered
You're out of me uncle Bing all right. Sorry. Sorry my friend is a very apologetic corner my poor friend
Ah, hey, hope you're insured
mr., policeman, huh
By the way this game is difficult all right good. Ah no a wrench II you know what forget it
I can't even wait I gotta get this guy never mind
I did neither of things that I wanted to do please you want pizzas
No Juke yuck, I'm dead Duke. You're riding to death
Jesus okay buy it please officer
Taking the hot air balloon Express up to heaven anyway. That's enough for this game. That was super fun
I had a great time with that one alright
So this game is super fun and unintentionally hilarious for absolutely intentionally Larry's. I highly recommend it
I'll put a link in the description below. I believe it was free
I'm pretty sure but obviously it runs like a potato so if you have a potato computer. It's like
What?
What my luck my character duh, oh there I go
Okay alright see ya, so thank you everybody so much for watching if you want to play this game for yourself
It's down in the description below. Let me know what you thinking if you want to see more games like this
Let me know in the comments as well. Thanks. Everybody so much for watching and as always I will see you in the next video